l'uniforme toujours mais à l'école cette
fois c'est le ministre xavier darcos qui
a lui même évoqué cette piste de
réflexion
après le débat sur la mixité l'époque
est décidément à la remise en cause pour
ses partisans l'uniforme est synonyme
d'effacement des différences qu'elle
soit religieuse ou sociale
pour ses détracteurs ce serait un pas en
arrière nabila taboury françois jullien
pied noir marine gris pas de baskets tee
shirt bleu ciel blanc le marine ou créer
un dans ce collège privé l'uniforme
n'est plus imposé depuis 30 ans il a été
remplacé par un camaïeu de gris et de
bleu
tenue correcte exigée sous peine deux
heures de colle ou de punition pour des
adolescents très attaché à la mode c'est
toujours difficile à accepter un peu
énervant de konami que des fois on
essaye de mettre un pull blanc est en
dessous en cash en tee shirt en imposer
une tenue donc des règles
une démarche qui se veut pédagogique
mais qui n'est pas forcément comprise
par tous les élèves vaut mieux avoir
soit un vrai nid phares on est
franchement bien tous pareils
ou alors pas digne et femmes parce que
l'uniforme sa sert a donc à gommer les
différences et je trouve que là elles
sont pas de mai
satouri je vois pas vraiment les
rapports avec les règles de la vie ni à
pourquoi vraiment l'utilité façon c'est
en faisait on n'a pas vraiment le choix
donc autant autant être pour le chiffon
1945 l'uniforme à l'école est de rigueur
il incarne la nécessaire égalité entre
les élèves faut-il y revenir aujourd'hui
au ministère de l'éducation on
s'interroge le débat est lancé avec ses
pur essai contre devant des problèmes de
racket devant un certain nombre de
problèmes liés à la laïcité
devant ce genre de problème on pourra
effectivement arrivé en dernier recours
au port de l'uniforme
je ne vois pas en quoi les élèves se
retrouverait par magie plus calme et
plus sera reparti très vite
revêtu d'un uniforme aujourd'hui à la
sortie des lycées et collèges publics
les jeunes sont très soucieux de leur
apparence en majorité ils disent nous un
retour de l'uniforme était important
tous les mêmes vêtements qu'on va
forcément réseau tous les problèmes qui
sont déjà causé pour le site et/ou dans
tout ce que vous voulez le problème
était déjà majeur avant tee shirts
bariolés baskets à la mode les vêtements
permettent aussi aux adolescents
d'affirmer leur propre personnalité